[Music]  beyoncé and jay-z's twins have arrived  and now their sexes have reportedly been  revealed I wanted it to be something  iconic and something that people would  never forget according to multiple  reports BAE and J welcomed their new  bundles of joy a boy and a girl to the  world last week the twins are the  couple's second and third children  together to be able to experience  bringing a child into this world if you  are lucky and fortunate enough to  experience Ted I would never ever take  that for granted the love on top singer  and her mobile husband who married in  2008 are also parents to five-year-old  daughter Blue Ivy the exciting news  comes after Beyonce broke the internet  with this shot in February announcing  she was pregnant and quote blessed to  times over  [Music]  you